Hollywood has a reputation for housing
secrets but sometimes with major casting
announcements the audience reaction
winds up being something like yawn we
already knew that followed by maybe a
polite golf clap golf club golf clam
this is because thanks to leaks in
common sense the public already scooped
the big news long before the studio made
it official here are a few of the worst
kept casting secrets in Hollywood brie
Larson as Captain Marvel there were a
bunch of names in play as to who'd
become Captain Marvel in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but once brie Larson
scored her Best Actress Oscar for room
she seemed like the obvious choice
because I love the way that she like
commands herself and owns her like woman
that she has the versatility the
critical cachet and she looks the part
so when rumors began that she was being
considered for the role she seemed like
a shoo-in the studio's announcement at
Comic Con that she'd been cast simply
confirmed what fans had already
suspected Alden Ehrenreich as han Solo
after Disney and Lucasfilm announced a
han Solo standalone prequel to Star Wars
the big question was who would play
young Han over 3,000 actors came out for
the part but the hail Caeser star was
considered the front-runner for weeks
before the studio revealed that they'd
land in Alden Ehrenreich this is the
best kept secret in Hollywood the
identity of this person is Alden
Ehrenreich
the only thing that's been surprising
about this news really is that he's
nabbed not just one feature film but a
potential trilogy hey you know what home
would say I got him bring him packing
Benedict Cumberbatch as Doctor Strange
Sherlock as the sorcerer supreme was
considered a winning combination ever
since Benedict Cumberbatch was first
rumoured to be attached to the Marvel
phase three pick not only to see a fan
favorite he's also a dead ringer for the
character so when Marvel finally
confirmed him as their choice for the
adaptation it made perfect sense
this doesn't make any sense Adam driver
in Star Wars The Force awakens when
girls star Adam driver was first rumored
to be attached to Star Wars The Force
awakens
then he expected him to play the bad guy
after several red herring efforts to
distract from the possibility Lucasfilm
finally confirmed his casting and he was
indeed playing the film's heavy kylo Ren
in addition as many also suspected ren
is the wayward son of han solo seems
like the force was strong with a rumor
mill this time
Matthew McConaughey in the Dark Tower
the Oscar winner was rumoured to be
circling Stephen King's apocalyptic
Western four months before King himself
confirmed that Matthew McConaughey and
Idris Elba would star as Randall Flagg
and gunslinger roland deschain
respectively the only real surprise for
King fans is how non mythical the
character is in the long-anticipated
movie version as opposed to the Mirage
like creature he was in the books even
so the official announcement of
McConaughey's role was news to almost no
one that I say me today I say alright
alright alright
Kurt Russell in guardians of the galaxy
to fans of Marvel's guardians of the
galaxy got to watch in real time as Kurt
Russell was cast in the sequel as star
Lords father you're half Terran your
mother was a vote your father
well he's something very ancient we've
never seen her before once he was
rumored to be eyeing the follow-up film
reporters caught up to him only to learn
that at the time he hadn't even seen the
first movie still Marvel eventually
confirmed Russell will indeed star in
the film after all as a sentient planet
that somehow fathered a regular-sized
human hey if we can love a talking tree
[Music]
thanks for watching subscribe to our
YouTube channel to watch more videos
like the one you just saw and leave us a
comment to let us know what you think of
these not-so-secret casting choices